Speaker 1: , let's go next. Let's go elsewhere.
OK, let's go to Richard from
California. Richard, you're on the air.
Richard, please go right into
your question, my friend.
Speaker 3: Hello, can you hear me?
Yes, I can. Hi, David. I've been a
long time listener, first time caller. I really
like I especially like your coverage during the
capital. Right. It really turned my dad from a
conservative to a moderate. Wow. That's good.
So I've been living in Los Angeles for a
long, long time. OK? And lately I just been
noticing that there's been like a lack
of empathy for the homeless population.
And my main concern is that because there are some
groups who are are for help or trying to help the
homeless. But the problem is that there's like a
large, like, pushback, like even our own sheriff,
even like when there was a plan to do like
affordable housing or free housing for them,
our sheriff said that, oh, no, like it's going
to like is going to entice people from other
states to come to our state. But he never offered,
like, a solution to it. Right. So my like my main
concern, like eventually like my question is, do
you think eventually, like our representatives or
people will start like calling like on for the
homeless to be sent to, like Death Valley or
to be like I don't want. I mean, listen,
Speaker 1: there's already people calling
for that sort of thing. I mean, it almost
starts to get concentration camp. You know,
here's the thing. We've had enough pilot programs
at this point to know how to deal with a problem
of homelessness, which is first, you've got
to provide the resources and allow people
to learn and make sure you help people learn
that they exist. And it's cheaper to house,
feed and provide health care to homeless people
than to criminalize homelessness or to try to push
homeless people around to different places. It
just makes more economic sense. Once you do that,
I'm open to the idea that, hey, these
resources are now available. If they are
now, we can start an information campaign about at
a certain point the encampments are not going to
be allowed anymore. Why? Well, because we have
the resources and having the resources is key.
But just shipping people off to Death Valley,
I mean, it's inhumane. It's crazy that that,
you know, I hope that that doesn't happen.
Speaker 3: All right. All right. Yeah,
it's just like I've been like ever since I
was young, I just remember, like the homeless
crisis, it was like small, but now it's
getting worse and worse. And I understand.
Yeah. Yeah. With the moratorium's and it's going
to get real worse. You remember Allami classmates
in Elementary. They lost their houses during the
financial crisis in a way, you know, terrible
and. Yeah. And a quick question. Like, do you
think like do you think because I've been a long
time listener, I was wondering, like, have you
kept in touch with Lewis or do you think he he can
make a guest appearance on it on a future show?
Speaker 1: Oh yeah. I see Lewis every
couple of weeks and he's welcome any
time. Maybe he'll join me on a live stream
soon or something like that.
Speaker 3: Oh, all right. Well,
thank you for taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. But
what part of L.A. are you in generally?
Speaker 3: Like in South Central like.
Like South Beach, California. Got it.
Speaker 1: OK. All right. Very good.
I appreciate the call. Thank you, David.
All right. Thanks to everybody who called
in today. I will not be taking more
calls right now, but we will take calls
again. All right, let's get into your emails, the
e-mail bag, so to speak, it's really more of a
folder. But, you know, I think the imagery
of the mailbag is still maybe relevant
in modern society. In twenty twenty one info
at David Pakman, Dotcom is the place to email.